now you have mcgregor fighting uh dustin
pourier right
he's like a high-end prostitute you know
oh really tell me more about that
he's a he's a high-end prostitute now
people want to go out
to another with him to show hey i have a
pretty girl with me
he's the pretty girl and after that when
you with her
you can go show other girls be like hey
i got this beautiful girl you want to
date me
that mean fighter they fight him but
they don't understand kagame
can have a one three years but you have
to steal
high priced hookers he's awkward he is
you understand
what's up everybody you guys welcome to
this episode of hop boxing with mike
tyson i'm your co-host triple c aka
henry cejudo and i'm mike tyson and who
we got here today has become my very
special handy
this is going to be a good one tonight
you know it is it is but you're talking
about the
american dream and every time i think of
ovali i think of the american dream
i'm going to put him in the arnold
schwarzenegger category because this man
has done
some extraordinary things the one and
only
the baddest manager on the planet ever
ali
what's up guys uh uncle mike thank you
so much
it's always goose pump when i say this
is slashing you know
having me on the same couch happy to
have you here brother
been a long time man you're very elusive
i'm just trying to move try to move up
what's up i
know the thing is with with him mike is
i've known this i've known ali
for since about 2004 and this goes back
because a lot of people just see
ali as uh as a manager i mean this guy
this guy went to the whole olympic ranks
of what it is
in judo in egypt and uh you know being
at the olympic training center
i mean you you want to kind of tell us a
little bit of your story i know
he's very attached to this fight no no
one of the things people don't know the
way i met henry i was an athlete
training for the olympics at the olympic
training center
and i lived there and henry lived there
and um it was in 2004 2003
and after that i started fighting what
made you want to start doing it i was
doing judo all my life since
when i was a kid you know and uh and i
come here for the u.s open and i kind of
stayed and i never went back
and the u.s team gave me an opportunity
to train with them and after that i met
henry
and i and i become a professional
fighter like mma fighter
i wasn't a great fighter i was like a
mediocre type of fighter and henry used
to
come to my fights when he was a wrestler
right that's back in the days
and that's how i know henry i know henry
for a long time and you know i fought
for a little bit and
and after that i transitioned to become
a you know a man
you think about from where you first met
him tonight what are you doing oh
man it's like i like this and i mean it
when i said when i say the american
dream i do think of ali
because man this from what i from from
the stories even that i've known me i
know you used to be a bouncer
in in colorado springs come on get the
[ __ ] out of here man
no no seriously i'ma tell you a story
like you know daniel cormier dc and
stuff like that
i got a job at this club and this is
true story and i used to be
they say the name of the club it's
called rambe nightclub right right
and i used to be the guy that said that
it's in colorado springs
it's on t honey street that's what the
training center yeah yeah and all the
olympic athletes come at night and the
military and stuff like that
and after that one day i was the guy who
picked up the ball as the cop
i was the busboy right but you know i
come from
from a different place and uh and a big
fight
broke down and a lot of the guys with
the olympic training center
big wrestler big guy stuff like that you
know
i did i broke the fight i did what i
have to do and the owner saw that
and the owner said you know what you're
not you're not a busboy anymore you're
going to become a bouncer
and uh but check this out in two months
i become the head bouncer of the club
daniel cormier
henry henry's coaches they used to come
to the club ali please catch a lot of us
in the club and i was the head bouncer
at this club
for like four years oh man [ __ ] i i i
was the head bouncer
you remember that [ __ ] oh yeah
absolutely and i used to take care of
all these guys when they come to the
club and stuff like that
but i become from a busboy to a headband
like in three months
well this this is what it was too with
ali man like he became so notorious
for being a bouncer and he was like the
meanest bouncer he used to
pop people used to pop
back then i changed i i changed a lot of
my ways because you know it used to be
like coming this military guys come
so angry and understand they're going
through and they come and they want to
fight and
and and it was a little bit crazy and um
and after that
you know the bounce on things is like i
think did it for three four years and
i become a fighter and uh after that i
and i one of the things uh side job i
used to have i used to live at the
olympic training center right
and this is a crazy story in new york
they used to have the fubu the nautica
from canal street
all the knockoff stuff like fake stuff
and a friend of mine
i was living on the olympic training
center with all the olympic athletes
but on sunday i used to open back in my
truck and i have like watches
fubu cv cd dvds everything and that was
my side hustle
and i used to make money
you know what i'm saying you know what i
say you know i used to make three
thousand dollars a week
back then constant hustler huh yes but i
was training
you know try in the olympics and i was a
bouncer and i was selling dvds but i
used to go all by the you know black
barber shops you know
and they used i used to go with the
bucks what's up i got what you need
and uh and everybody showed me a lot of
in colorado springs and denver
shout out to all these people and um and
i always like to work you know because
he's just a little world traveler huh
holly no because i'm beyond that i had i
had like 20 people in egypt
i have my mother my sister i i had to
take care of them i know
they have no income they can't even eat
like sometime
when i was young i couldn't i i slept to
do with no food
because we like eight people we lived in
a two two bedroom apartment
my mother was sick my father was older
economy is bad and we live
we live in islam you know we live in
islam but the islam in egypt is very
different it's not bad it's it's
it's very religious like very
conservative but b was very poor
and i come here really to kind of change
that life of my life and it worked out
well for me and i'm grateful
yeah thank you yeah and i think i think
the biggest thing with
ali his turning point and and talk about
this a little bit alex i know your story
man
it's kind of crazy i'm talking about
myself next time i feel very no i don't
know but this is very um
trust me everybody everybody is
intrigued because
this man mike the world is misunderstood
why do you say that what is it about you
about him that you know
no one else no because he's a passionate
person
exactly you know what i'm saying he's
law man we have to be loyal to him
it's like they fight him they fight all
of us somebody fights me they fight all
of us
you know what i'm saying
[Laughter]
talk a little bit about uh about how
henzo how hanzo gracie changed your
pretty much man he he gave you the way
man
yeah i moved in i used to live in pet
style new york that's where i used to
live and uh
and i i train out hands of gracie in
manhattan i used to take the train the a
train
every day mike used to live it was it
was very rough you know
and i was the only guy there i look like
i don't fit there but
realistically
but i'm the original black man people
doesn't notice i am original i'm proud
to be black
you understand african you know anyway i
fought in japan one time and i lost
and uh at this point i didn't have any
money i didn't have nothing going on for
me and henzo gracie i used to help him
in the gym right
henzo gracie's a legend and uh and he's
very much
you know i used to help her guys around
the gym like they fight in the small
shows for free
make no money and answer said hey i want
to come back and fight in the ufc
and that was in 2009 i said okay
and i'm back then my english my accent
was so heavy
and he's like no no i want you you help
me reach out to ufcs bro
i never i don't know these people and
somebody said talk to joe silva and i
talked to joseph i said no no
this is above my bay great you need to
talk to dana white i don't know
i know who he is but i don't know him
you know
reach out as assistant set up a meeting
but i think everything was set up
already because henzo gracie was
attached to sheikh tahnun
who at the time on 10 percent of the ufc
and we had to go to vegas
and that was my first meeting with ufc
people normally meet the matchmaker
he have couple champion he meet dana you
know
um and after that was lorenzo vertida
sitting down
who became very close friend of mine a
mentor of mine and dana
also and we went in there i said hey if
you want to
have me there hanzo you can't say
nothing and hence would say what the
heck what are you talking about senses
and dana start talking and stuff like
that but everybody said dana white was a
scumbag
he was the lowest of the lows right
people told me that amen be careful
this guy is bad and after that the guy
was generous they have food for us they
have drinks
and everything it was in the office and
he would start talking i said you know
what man
i don't care what everybody said about
you everybody's and he's like
what everybody said about me i said man
like
lauren said no no we want to know i said
everybody see an [ __ ]
and everybody started laughing you know
and since this day
uh you know dana white is that who's
somebody i look up to and become friends
we'll make the deal
hands of a and this is how i got
connected to this ufc thing you know
and i become a promoter after that and
when you become a promoter data become
your enemy right
and i i got this blessing him and
lorenzo and let me become a promoter
at one point and that's how i kind of
started my ufc run you know
um yeah yeah it's interesting because he
had that he took that
it was hansel gracie and hansel gracie
he comes from the gracie family
he's found the ufc he's one of the
pioneers of the sport of of
of mixed martial arts and man now you're
kind of paving the way forward now ali
like look at
he's been able to hand you the baton but
but but in reality
hanzo didn't need me as a manager henzo
really want to help me out
hanzo kind of got the best manager he
didn't need nothing right
but he really opened the door for me to
start a career and i'm
always going to be grateful to him i'm
always going to be loyal to him you know
he's
without him i wouldn't be here yeah
like i i you know a lot of people talk
about loyalty too much and
and sometimes it makes me upset because
loyally loyalty is not just talk it's
action you understand or not
and that's one thing i i really take
pride of you know just
like being loyal like like like you know
and sometimes
i do stuff out of character for just
getting angry at someone like
rob somebody or there's something wrong
with somebody or
just say something about somebody you
remember the night who was watching the
fight together
even though he wants to attack somebody
yeah
it's just that he's just passionate you
know but i'm not saying it's right but
this is about it you know
yeah how did you guys how did you guys
hurt me mike do you remember
how long ago how long ago was it
like five years at least probably five
or six years five six years
um the way we met uh
i don't know if you want to say or your
mistake you just say
uh rob i know rob because rob was a
little listen rob i think i see you
before you
come to the um ufc fights all the time
yeah
we met there one time i was always coked
out of my mind
fat mike is to come hang out all the
time check this out
i never in my life ask a celebrity an
actor
like give me like a photo or do a photo
with me or something like that
i think mike tyson is the only guy who
sounded like famous guy
in my life to ask for a photo and every
time i meet him
i i would take a photo and i'll and i'll
post it it's like a bragging right hey
i know mike dassen like the whole thing
is people
i was talking to prince khalid who's the
you met him before he's who's the guy
putting on anthony joshua
uh uh the gypsy king what's his name a
tyson phillips
that is a very fight right and uh we was
talking
actually three days ago i said you know
i met so much
celebrity tom brady this this this i
said the only guy
going publicly worldwide not only in
america
like trombore 80 people know him in
america he's famous in america right but
i'm talking about an
international grover superstar you know
muhammad ali is the good but i think
mike tyson
he's the most famous most recognized
human on this planet today you know i'm
saying it's not michael jordan he's not
michael jackson
yeah it's not even
like people in africa who don't have
water they know mike tyson
people are living in a mansion in kings
they know mike tyson
mike tyson is not an icon my classes
have become
a culture as a lifestyle right you know
everybody want to be like mike right
and even mike and i now i thought about
right we had dinner at the circa hotel
and uh and i see something very
different right
normally people know thomas my children
here go ahead
this is true this is honest well it is
the truth and
uh and i see an 80 years old say hello
to mike we went to the circle we come
out at dinner
i went with habib with dana white to
dinner it was with
giannis you know jana's the basketball i
was with him last week
i never see in my life the whole entire
hotel people left a table gambling
they playing the guys doing a sports
book
we have at least 2 000 people surrounded
mike
from four different generations from
eight years old
six years old 20 years old
but check this out but i'm talking about
people
from four different generations they
know mike tyson
you understand if you put on a mike
tyson fight
a verse coca-cola which my kids would
say if you put on a mike tyson
fight versus a coca-cola bottle will be
the biggest fight
in history every time right and this is
why
how mike tyson is five different
generations know mike tyson right
i think mike tyson is a brand forever
mike tyson is you know mostly the muslim
word is one
1.7 billion muslims right and they're
all mike tyson fans
but even people jewish christian hebrews
atheists they all love might well i was
the only one
you
i saw this i saw like eight years old
seven years old four years old
nine eighteen years old kids who's
coming together right
and this is kind of like when we're
sitting here we're like nothing
you understand what this daughter's
gonna think i have a 12 year old
daughter she's gonna they got paid jobs
that's what i i tell mike all the time
and i feel like you know i feel like uh
muhammad ali man
gave apache the baton mike you know i
think a lot of fighters feel that you
know do you
do you feel that mike hey i just don't
want to be imprisoned by that
some people get imprisoned by that
person or that stigma
energy whatever it is i don't want to be
imprisoned by that i want to be able to
hang out with you like this at a
restaurant or somewhere but
you know you you're lost forever and i'm
not trying to switch this topic to you
but i have to like at 57 years old
uh you lost fight right 54 whatever
60 whatever how old you are right that
one
but i'm talking about you going in there
looking in this phenomenal shape you
know how many people you inspired
it wasn't only about the the money how
many people got inspired
in your age or even 20 years younger to
be like wow if you can do it at 50 in
the 50s
i'm in my 20s i have to i lost 100
pounds in four months
i saw it i saw it i was eating the i was
going to dinner with you
and we hung out i saw it but the whole
thing is this is a
it take uh it's just uh it's just a
different kind of power
and it's inspiring me right i said [ __ ]
i kind of have mike that's to look
better than me well you can't change the
world unless you change yourself
yep yes sir yes you know it is it is
that's awesome well i'll leave
can you you know for the fans that are
for all the viewers that are watching
here
can you name some of the athletes that
you currently are representing now
man uh you know i i represent that well
name the ones you don't represent
you got so many of them right you know
like you know i represent you know
as you know camaro uh khabib the triple
c
henry sahuru justin geishi i prince
islam mahachaf banil darush you just
beat tony ferguson
marvin vittori is fighting israel sunny
for the title
derrick bronson who's the number one
contender after him brad tavares uh
anthony rambo johnson um so many guys
frankie heavyweight now anthony johnson
he's a light heavyweight yeah
he met auntie remember anthony johnson
he just knocked out a guy
unconscious and last week he did right
you know he almost killed
you know he's a very dangerous and he
haven't fought for four years and come
back
it looked in great shape and knocked out
a guy like that right
corey anderson you know i have a lot of
kayla harrison
kayla two-time olympic champion the goat
kelly harrison
um giga you know kevin gaslin
so many so many vardoom you know so many
um the west camera i know cable kayla
she did with the pfl yeah she was pfm
right now
um i'm i see here on the list we're
going to talk about her later she i
i believe she's the goal i'd like to see
her fight somebody
yeah for sure speaking about that uh
kayla harrison and clarissa shields
what's your take on that mike i don't
know i don't know i want to see carissa
fight a ufc fight
you know i i don't know if we're gonna
strike her she's gonna be
a grappler as well this is what i think
about if you don't know both of those
damages this is what i think about like
uh
it's easier from a wrestler to become a
good striker
but is it harder from a striker to
become a good wrestler yeah that could
be
what's your predictions in that fight if
they ever do fight uh
you know you know it's a big brother a
little sister big sister i think uh
uh in in in a in 60 second kilo smash
her face
i'll tell you what though that's two
olympic gold medals
there's no disrespect to carissa right
it's level to this and i don't think
carissa is just getting her feet wet you
know like she is a two-time olympic gold
medalist
kayla harris is a two-time olympic gold
medalist but kara's nine and one
nine and oh she's been doing this for
three years she's a world champion
already
if you want to compare it's tough if you
want to compare said
who win amanda nunes they know what
she's the goat i think dana's wrong
and no disrespect dana i think kayla
harrison
is the pound for pound the greatest
woman on the planet today i think
she's uh i'm she's a two-time olympic
champion
nobody laughs around with her and the
whole thing is amanda nunes she's an
entail of her career i don't think she
can stop kayla's take down thank you
thank you
i think harry is just blossoming i i i
think amanda nunes is like
you know what do you think henry man i
think i
the way she's been looking ali mike is
right
but the whole thing is she's fighting
people they're not they're not supposed
to be
there for us she's not fighting kayla
harrison he's not one of the chances ali
that that maybe dana white allows the
cross promotion of a pfl versus the ufc
listen do you think that'll ever be
doable
i have to be the money uh i i i think
i don't think will be ever doable
because the ufc is so far
ahead of everybody they are espn they
have billions dollar deal
they sort of everybody it makes no sense
for dana white it makes sense for dana
white to say
kayla harrison is gonna be gonna become
a free asian in november in december
right
it's her last year's pfl and i'm not
saying she's gonna leave pfl because
i'm loyal to these guys i like these
guys right but in a way
there's nobody left for her to beat and
kayla she's a two-time olympic gold
medalist and mentor is different
she want to be the greatest right she
got five nunes she got a fight we have
to find a way to fight dunya
cyborg first in you know what my
my my man listen uh you know i like
cyborg i think she's amazing
but i don't think any of these girls
stand the chance of killing i like to
see a fight cyborg
you know i don't but in a way cyborg is
in bellator amanda news in the ufc
kayla i can see pfl doing a co-promotion
with bellator before they do but
i'm just i'm telling you she she's a
different
i want to see a fight again against the
top of that
yeah but it's uh you know let's go ahead
and move the subject here ali i
want to talk a little bit about khabib
obviously you saw the fight with
uh with oliveira and chandler how would
you match up
oliveira against it could be because i
feel like i i got my two cents to say
but i want to hear from the man listen
just
just i think khabib is the greatest
fighter of all the time
you know the man never lost a round uh
barely lost
never got a black eye in a fight never
got cut and you see ufc fight
like savages they bleed in they're
hurting they're breaking the arm there
the man never been touched right mike
chandler versus aloe vera that was
the the the fifth place at the olympics
fighting the seventh
it's not even the bronze medals of the
governors they two guys
the the ufc dana white is such a smart
guy
the best guy there is justin geishi uh
dustin pourier
you know this is the best two guys but
he said charles oliveira never fought
khabib
uh mike chandler never [ __ ] khabib if i
make this fight
fight each other be like oh they never
lost the khabib right
i can have a champion without a mark on
him but realistically
you know charles oliveira he's a good
fighter
you know it's a different between
landing service was a go fighter mike
tyson is a great fighter as a legend
right yeah charles oliver is a good
fighter khabib is a great fighter he's
and he's a level to this you know what
would you what would your prediction
that five-third to fight how do you
think khabib wins
and and inside inside one round insane
brahma i think khabib smash him
he make him question himself because
charles oliver always questioned himself
he breaks
right and i think khabib this is his
bread and butter he makes people
question himself
he's really a ferocious yeah is there
anything that will get khabib to come
back so i know we had talked about it
earlier is a georgetown purifier would
that ever entice khabib to come back
i'm gonna break some news here two weeks
ago ten days ago dana white called me
and he said george saint pierre he said
he'll fight khabib
non-title fight 165 pound
but in a way we've been waiting for
george for allah he's my friend
i'd like to we got to get george here
you know uh
we've been waiting for george for four
or five years i'm coming i'm not coming
and oh there's some [ __ ] going on for a
minute
you know it's just at the end of the day
the ufc want to make him to fight
to light weight he want to do a
welterweight kabhi was the lightweight
champion
but now said hey khabib is retired i'm
retired
what about coming back and fight khabib
now but you know kabika offered 100
million dollars
after he's retired to fight for
mayweather 100 million is that crazy fun
100 million
you can ask floyd you can ask everybody
and khabib said
no i'm retired i told my mother i'm
retired
i did you know i'm gonna keep my work to
my mother right
if my mother told me to fight again
maybe i will but right now she told me
not to fight
you know he come from a muslim culture
we respect our mother very dearly
you know we can't go to heaven without
our mother permissions and george now
he wanted to come uh and fight khabib
right
and in a way to be honest like as a
human
i don't want to see george and pierre in
this he's 40 years old today
it's his birthday right uh you know
khabib is a 30 years
you know he's a the men wrestle bears
and alligators and
lions and you know it's you know like
why um
they both have the same game but khabib
is much younger more
more ferocious you know and i i don't
think it would be even a fair fight it
will make fans want to see it though
i don't want to see it yes the fans
gotta give the fans what they want
what's your what's your take if you're
to see uh
khabib and george shampier mike what do
you how do you think that how do you
think that fight turns out i don't know
i haven't seen george
fight he was like he stopped fighting
longer than um khabib did didn't he
yeah listen last time he fought
four years ago i don't know he's four
years old
he was 32 years old you know i don't
think the age man is desired by his
khabib i think he's invisible but i have
an idea
and you know i think you're a great
promoter yourself
i think you your your brain you have the
best brain and come to martial art or
fighting
george and pierre he wants to come back
he wanted someone
untouchable right that's true
the bound for pound king right now the f
the nigerian nightmare camaro usma
the man never lost a fight in the ufc
never got touched in the ufc he smashed
everybody right
is he the same way to judge in a way if
you want to come back and fight somebody
invincible
like you want hey are the same way they
the same way yeah same way
come back george simply i can come back
fight camaro usman
i'll be more than happy the ufc be more
than happy
and will be a such a huge fight right
but this
you tell me if i'm wrong the dude trains
every day
the dudes the dude's constantly in the
gym like he trains like he's never
retired
right so what i'm saying if you're gonna
do awesome
you want a big fight i think that's
going to determine who the goat is but
now i agree with you ali camaro broke
the record of george champier he have
more winning streak than him at walter
white division
if you want to fight camaro osman will
fight him no problem
i don't think that's the fight that
should happen but i think george
also smart you know camaro osman we see
him
um how he dismantle uh
george mas fadol and and george did he
want to get hurt
getting knocked out like that at this
age of his life maybe not you know
maybe he thinks yourself he is a natural
walk away right he's a natural
alterweight yes all right
i'm gonna let you have it then how do
you see the predictions of usman versus
gsp if there are two fights i i think
it's a good fight i think george
steele train is in shape but i think
kamar will not come out
i really do i i this is why george will
not take a fight i gotta do this fight
you know you heard it here tell him i
gotta do this fight without george
you know i love george but i think
camaro i think come out right now will
knock anybody out
it doesn't matter camaro become from
judges hard to hit though he is hearted
he have great wrestling i think it's an
intriguing fight
ground game is awesome very good ground
game
honestly it's it's it's a really good
fight because i know kamaru is 34
they're not big in h they're not you
know i think it's an intriguing fight
i don't think george is going to get
killed because i think george
we never really see anybody kill george
right you never see anybody kill george
he's very smart for a lot of great
fighters though he fought allegra fight
but i'm just telling you
if you're going to compare who's the
greatest walter with all the time now
you cannot say georgetown pierre because
george zimpier
been a split decision been in close
fight camaro osman is killing everybody
he's been knocked out and submitted
before and he he'd been knocked out he'd
been submitted camaro has not been
touched right
and i think that's just experience if
you want to come back and make it
knock out that stuff just experience
yeah but in a way camaro
have not been there but he have more
winning in the welterweight division
winning streak than george who gonna
claim like
like like we talk about john we talk
about goat confrontation right
right now jon jones camaro
camaro usman espn ring camaro osman
is the number one pound for pound right
john said i am i think it's camaro osman
is
because jon jones have split decision
last three fights
all closed fight right and camaro osman
is just killing people in the last three
fights right yeah and in a way
jon jones have not fought for a year and
a half camaro osman
he fought three months and three times
in 10 months
i tell you what i'll you know what i
would love because he's been so dominant
mike
kamaru has been so dominant in the watch
i mean he's been knocking i mean there's
no but he's lapping people
in reality he is it's me as his brother
i talked to him a couple days ago
actually yesterday i talked to him
yesterday
i think he should go up man i think i
think i think it's time for him to go up
and fight for another
title another belt
mike but if he doesn't come he's already
lapped there but who's next kobe
covington
i i agree i agree with mike i think the
fight to make is your champion
i do agree with mike yeah dudes got to
fight why is he even playing around with
it
you know listen time is now i don't
think he's going to kill that i think
he'll be a good fight do you think that
i think george is like real smart
yeah but that's up to george hey if you
have a message for georges right now
what do you tell him
[Laughter]
i say face this it just wanted to fear
the son i think he should face it
and i don't think it's gonna turn out as
bad as he thinks it is either
i think he's gonna do okay damn there
you
have it you have it gsp you're hearing
it from my iron mike tyson what's up
and i love george i respect him but in a
way like
if you want to fight khabib you go ahead
and fight kamara usma i mean yeah i
think he should fight that's
regular his natural weight those two
guys exactly
nobody got to come up nobody has to come
down exactly because
you know as a boxing mic you go five
pounds
huge difference you won 20 and this
guy's 125 that's a lot of weight yes
yes well camaro usman is this next fight
against colby covington i i really have
to talk about this fight because
now we talk when camaro bro you know
camaro broke his shot right uh
you know he he knocked him out yeah yeah
he broke his jaw to the title of him
right yeah no no they were fighting for
the
uh uh kobe covington was fighting for
us had the title camaro beat woodley and
after that he was defending his title
against kobe
since camaro beat kobe kamaru defended
his title three times
in ten months kobe fought three times in
three years
and he fought one time after camaro beat
him
and he beat woodley woodley is not in
the ufc anymore right
as a champion normally the champion that
won't wait
he's very active right now kamaru broke
your jaw
knocked you out you should have stayed
active to prove hey
i deserve it right right now nobody
deserves nothing
nobody's there for nothing if marvin
vittori fighting israel designing a june
12th right
you know from kings right if marvin
vittori win i talked to him today
if marvin vittori win he will fight
camaro i know camaro didn't want to
fight israel because they fought
their boss friend they're from nigeria
and i don't get involved with that
if they're friends i'm never going to
push him to fight his friend if you
don't want to right
but marvin vittorio is not his friend
camaro can go up and fight marvin
vittorio for the middleweight title oh
[ __ ]
he's your friend supposed to fight you
help him get some money yeah but listen
i i
this is what part of my practice is
right if two guys
if you're my friend and you really care
about me and i care about you
we should fight and get some money well
how are we gonna make some money
he's just old school mentality you know
how we gonna fight we will rob somebody
now
yeah yeah i'm kind of with mike on this
footage
it's the same reason why you fought roy
jones yeah yeah
listen i i this is the mentality i like
i agree with you
and i think the fight to make his
camaros man
if he wins or marvin wins this is what i
think
or georgetown yeah that's that that's
that golden match right there
yeah you can go to canada and sell out
50 000 arena with this fight i mean
speaking of everybody's talking about
kamaru now what who is it jake paul jake
we're talking about jake paul again mike
he wants a piece of camaro too
man could you ever see a fight with
kamaru and jake paul
aligning in boxing i don't see that [ __ ]
you want to see it mike you're going to
listen um
community it's going to be so much
[ __ ] money how can you turn it down
mike's a businessman he doesn't want
more money than
twice or three times as much money as
ufc how's he gonna be able to turn it
down
me and uh it's true me and me and kamara
and then i discussed that last monday we
had a meeting actually
we had dinner listen jake paul is a
young kid
you know he's making a high for himself
i can't hate on him
you know make your money but i feel
you know jake paul doesn't have a
promoter don't have a
promoter you know my opinion right now
the greatest promoter of comeback
history now is dana white right
the ufc have 120 country distribution
pay-per-view they have platform right
dana white is not going to go promote a
fight
i know what's the name of the website
which would be that
trailer yeah whatever whatever this
trailer thing is right they're going to
go ahead and
dana white himself he's a he's a real
billionaire yeah i'm not i'm not i'm
going to stick with dan if they're
[ __ ] with trevor
you know you know what i'm saying but
i'm talking forget about we like we
don't like
but he's the baddest the greatest he's
got to make you the most money
if jake paul want to make real money he
like floyd right
when floyd wanted to make money was
mcgregor who's the promoter
dana white was the promoter right dana
white used the ufc machine to promote
the fight
become big become huge right and if jake
paul right now
he doesn't have contract with the letter
if he really won't
make fight a ufc fighter because now the
trend
to fight camaro usman to fight the ufc
fighter
these guys act like the billionaires the
trailer guys but they're not
billionaires
they know why it's a real billionaire
the ufc is a billion dollar company
you align yourself with people who is
going to make the most money
and also going to give you the platform
right and these guys
they've been losing money every they
saying they sold 1.6 million
the second day of the fight how are you
going to pre pay-per-view business
you don't get the numbers for 30-40 days
right shaking his head man what's up
mike saying
they didn't get that many they no they
lie their line is a form of
promoting right but you can't lie like
that because when you lie like that
i'm gonna be like my fighters you have
to pay jake paul 40 50 million dollars
because you said 1.5 right
but they created a fake hype but fake
hype can last for so
long right you have to be honest when
you do business right when you say hey i
sold
five hundred thousand pay-per-view okay
that's what you saw
it it doesn't matter but in a way i
don't know these guys and
you should know you can't be talking
[ __ ] about dinner white is the biggest
troll
he he's he never you lose public feud
and now this guy's talking about him
you can't if you talk about it he wants
his name in the paper don't talk about
this guy yeah for sure but in a way like
i say
if jake paul or these guys they want to
make they want to fight kamar or
something like that
they have to knock on dino white's door
they can't come to me because
i'm not the promoter i'm the manager
i'll make the deal on camaro's behalf
but in a way yes if if jake paul want to
get his ass woof
by an an african line he can come and
get it because our in their day
he will mail to this guy yes speaking
about fights ali
what is missing to make this fight
happen with uh
jon jones and francis nungano man and
then i want to know your predictions
first how is it that this fight can kind
of flourish
and then what's your take and also you
mike i want to know your two two cents
on that
you can go hit mike first i don't know i
don't see this fight going too well for
younger guys size
his aggression his improvement over the
years he's been in the ufc
and i would think what would john do
would he put on more weight
or would he fight him yesterday at 107
and uh john
jones john jones is about 250 already
the dude is already here
it's not really weight it's not real
weight it's fakeway what is it
what has to be done for that fight to
take placements that's i know you're
super close to dana
john's gonna have to box him oh jab
punching yeah but before he does all
that how can this fight take place
i i think this is what what happened
here
you know john is he's very much
taken out of his own hand right you pay
people to work for you to get deals done
to do this
and john he decided to go public with
dana
about money right i think big people bp
real people real people don't talk about
money in public
you talk about money the usda and alarms
this guy's a real gangster
you know you don't talk to gangsters
about money in public about problem but
you go sit down behind closed door
man to man and talk about your problem
right
you're going to agree and disagree but
when a fighter starts talking about
money publicly
you make yourself cheap you make
yourself cheap the jon jones deserves
money yeah i think john jones deserves a
lot of money i agree with him
all fighters have to be paid if you give
him
10 million he said you want 20. if you
give him 30 they want 60.
this is the nature of the business right
but i think the
the problem with jean jones dana white
it's it's a
dana's are hard to hear it too and if
you go public
feud with him he's going to beat you
every time right
you know and in a way now dana's saying
about he's going to fight derrick lewis
francis ingano when he win he's going to
fight stippy
john is not even in a conversation john
is 30
35 years old he's not getting any
younger the ufc is making money every
day every day
and the person is not making money is
jean jones and you can buy anything in
life
anything except one thing time you
cannot buy
time back right yeah and i think sean
john is like
he have to get personal dana sit down
with him and talk with him right
and dana is so easy to
to work with it's not as hard people
think dana white is such a monster
he's a savage he used to be but now the
new dana white is actually he's a
very level-headed is he a teddy bear
though
huh is he a teddy bear he's no no
[ __ ] he's not no teddy bear
but i'm gonna tell you something he's
more calm he's more understanding
but in a way you wanna you wanna go like
that with him
you understand you're never gonna win
because the ufc is gonna move on and
make money put shoes on every year
you're the one losing time i i hope i
want to see this fight happen between me
and francis i think it's a big fight
you know but i wish jean jones started
going
public with this go meet dana have
dinner with him
and try to a lot of people reach out to
me i see why you don't manage john why
don't manage on i talked to john before
a couple of times
but in a way if i manage somebody i'm
gonna be like yo you gotta sit down
you gotta trust me like khabib like
kamar like henry
he let me do my job you pay me i a
manager i work for the fight i'm an
employee
by the fighter i'm not the star but you
pay me to do this let me do my job
but i think john is the type of guy i
want to take matter in his own hand on
twitter and instagram
and this is he you are he's a legend you
should not do that
and him fighting francis it's hard not
to bet on francis when
yeah it's his hands his hands are hot it
is he's just friends
he's just it's it's dangerous everywhere
you go you know
and uh he possessed this kind of power
jean doesn't possess smart
too yeah we've been smarter over the
years what's your predictions mike
what's your predictions jones
nunganu next year who who wins it who
take who takes off
they're gonna fight again before they
fight someone else i don't think that's
what is gonna happen
right i think francis again is gonna
fight lewis no for sure but
hypothetically what do you think
i want to see them fight again i want to
see jones fights i didn't like jones
last fight was very complicated
before the arabian guy yeah i believe
what about you ali what's your take on
it it's it's hard listen to me john is
he's a winner you know he's he never
lost in the ufc and that's what he's
here
he's a winner he always find a way to
win but in a way francis is so dangerous
and and john lately he's this guy's
catching up to him
he's close fight he's been in close
fight wins
against the guys getting knocked out
like the guy who split decision
two of them they both got knocked out in
the second round
by some guy he's not even this good jean
right
and i think i don't know if jean put it
on this weight is going to help him
or he's going to slow him down because
john is not a fast guy
he's not a fast explosive he's
long he uses range well
it's it's listen john is a winner but
francis ingano is a killer
he's a monks yeah you know
it's a fight for sure we all want to see
and i hope this fight can happen
of course well it will of course man mom
and uh i'll email any any any new
approximately closing thoughts here man
that you want to
do you want to share with with the
people uh you know i um
we talk about christa shield you know i
think she need they need to take her
time with her
she's making her debut i wish her the
best of luck she always tweeted me she
think i don't like her
but i like her you know she's a sister i
wanted to see yeti do well
but uh but i think people need to take
her time with her
you understand don't rush her the way i
built keller harrison
yeah i brought her she was on all now
she's not an o
you cannot let you cannot allow the
promoter to push you
i believe you know the greatest female
fighter on the planet today is killer
harris
you know and mike you guys talked to
before you know we talked about camaro
osman and maswa don't fight
we didn't talk about this fight what do
you what do you think about this fight
mike
the master um he's just so he's
too much for him you know yeah from the
first fight ali to now it's like
kamaru just turned into another animal
another monster
i think what happened is camaro
the first fight he took this fight on
five days notice he left
went home and they called me saying
let's make this fight happen and very
much
it was everybody that excuse me
i'll take this fight on six days notice
kamara did too you know
but i feel everybody comes this must for
the hype right
you know muslim knocked out ben askren
but you see what happened to ben asker
right
ben asker is not this guy who's you know
he's an okay fighter but i'm talking
about
people and when you see marvel doll
fight week come with rappers
cars bentley roads rises you know what i
did with camaro
we stay at the fighter hotel we'll close
the doors
nobody can hang out to us we train eat
and sleep he was
out in town videos and you become
more of a show not a fight right
when you come to fight kamaru usman
who's a
you know a cold-blooded killer he's a
killer right you have to have some focus
you understand you want to come with
these fastashi ropes and
all this stigma you know what i'm saying
it's only
one floyd mayweather you understand
that's just him
everybody want to be floyd mayweather
but the bank account is half maybe a
million dollars
or maybe less he can't be floyd and
floyd is a master
he already used to this type of a
pressure right
but when you get a guy like most of
those with his rappers he have like
rappers and this and girls and all this
kind of stuff
he's a great fighter he's a good guy i
don't know him simply
seem like a good but i'm talking about
when you see all these people
your whole cuban spanish community on
your back but
you're not there yet you're not the
champion
right it put pressure on the fighters
right and i i advise when you see your
team or your management or whatever
want to put this kind of pressure on you
said no no i gotta focus fight week let
me focus
let me and i locked camaro in the room
i'm not joking
it was nobody no pictures because i know
such an important fight for his legacy
in his flight
you cannot lose to this guy you
understand and we went in there
camaro have an amazing training camp
which trevor wolfman who's actually a
boxing coach
make his hand looking sharp and we went
in there
it was a fight we killed or be killed
right but i feel
mozvodal win there he's a fighter he's a
real fighter but he has so much
distractions too yes speaking about uh
what's your take on the lightweight
division i would just engage him and how
everything's kind of planned next i
almost feel like he got
you know you know they they kind of
neglected him a little bit the only guy
that's really being
uh him was has been khabib what's your
take on gateshead where does he fit in
that picture
i think listen now we have mcgregor
fighting uh dustin pourier right
you know they're gonna fight each other
uh probably mcgregor gonna quit again
you know because he's a quitter he quit
i know last time i
i was on you broadcast i killed him but
i i he's for to me is irrelevant
you know okay i remember to tell him
that he's
he's irrelevant now he's he's a guy like
he's like a high-end prostitute oh
really tell me more about that he's a
he's a high-end prostitute
now people want to go out to another
with him
to show hey i have a pretty girl he's
the pretty girl
and after that when you with her he can
go show
other girls be like hey i got this
beautiful girl you want to date me
that mean fighter they fight him and
they get this cloud they get the look
they get this
stigma with him fighting conor mcgregor
but they don't understand cargo machine
haven't won
three years but you have to steal a
high-priced
hooker he's okay he is you understand
and uh and in a way like now you got all
these guys
he's just become a stepping stone but
also
you make money when you fight conor
mcgregor because he's a draw right but
how long is this going to last for
you know i don't know him and that's
temporary i like dustin but both look
like [ __ ] on the fire yeah
connor beat him up the first round the
second round it didn't make no sense
right it makes no sense
right but at the end of the day like uh
you have a lot of killers you have just
engaged i believe he's the best
lightweight he should fight the guy to
just be
um tony they're both
you know but now they say they'll fight
each other for the title if they want to
fight tomorrow go for it
it's up to them to go all out um but
let's see what happens july 10
and justin gishi i believe he's the best
lightweight in the world today
but you have you have but the whole
thing is you have islam
who's khabib is is his younger brother
coming up you have benilder which coming
up
who trained with kings who's master
raphael he's a killer right
you have a lot of guys who's gonna beat
all these guys in the top five
you have the new guys coming up who is
better than the mcgregor
the party a all these guys right
but at the end of the day like you know
the mcgregor
thing is finished it's it's uh you know
mcgregor now is going to be fighting
jake paul
and he fighting he's going to fight the
kardashians the girl
he's going to fight chicks hey
mike i'll find kim kardashian man
[Laughter]
you know but you know that's what's
going on now is that you know
like like like like i want to ask a
question
and they're because you think jake paul
and
ben asked was a fix fact or a real
knockout real deal do you think it was a
real deal i'm so happy to refuse
them again huh i'm glad the referee
didn't let jake hit that guy because a
lot of people said
they think it's a fix expenditure fake
yeah no it's it's a true he got he got
clocked with that right hand and
ben's not a boxer he's not a striker it
was unfair you know what i'm saying they
should let me fight man ice cream
oh you punch him out too you kidding me
don't hurt them
then it's probably his pride is hurt so
bad i don't think so i think
he's going there you know he's not going
to win yeah
well that's what's up man well i'll
leave man it's been uh
it's it's been awesome man at the time
that i've had a chance to get to know
you ali
and how fighters from russia from the
middle east
pakistan utility everybody the world man
the way they treat this man from mexico
to everyone i mean i'm just man i would
i would love to be praised like him mike
you know what i'm saying
people respect them he works people like
every bit of
it but but you know what mike one of the
things that like like sometimes
you know talking to you and talking to
this and sometimes people believe in
their own hype
and the one thing i always say i'm a
servant from many masters henry
who is my master camaro khabib and even
the
young fighters who doesn't make money i
treat him like that champion you know
and i always say i'm a servant of many
masters and i
i'm just a guy who cleaning a room who
making the bed taking the garbage out i
never think i'm somebody
like because these guys really put their
life on the line you know and i'm not
putting my life on the line like that
and i'm grateful for all these guys and
i'm grateful for you mike to give me
your time thank you thank you brother
stop this [ __ ] you know i'm going for
you to stop this [ __ ]
people love you too the only person that
loves
one more thing too one of the my my
craziest moment of my life right
i it happened i got in some like a
little fight
one night was mike i said mike i'll come
back and i go
i want to handle this one guy he was
talking a little bit crazy and i
shouldn't
and mike after i said man you can you
can be fighting people like that and i
was like
i was like what's wrong with the world
it's like i got mike tyson told me to
chill
you know that was happening about you
doing too much
out there and after that i didn't i i
cut it off yeah i did you know what
you have to stay the definite
sophisticated gentleman that you are
thank you thank you well that's what's
up man let's end it through on that no
alia de laziz thank you for being here
hot boxing with mike tess i'm your
co-host triple c aka henry cejudo
and i'm mike tyson have a good day we
[Music]
out
[Music]
you